welcome everybody my name is todd story
i'm the chief communications officer for
the clark county school district um what
we'll do is we will start this off with
trustee evelyn garcia morales then
followed up with superintendent dr jesus
jarrah principal ryan lewis from
garaheim elementary school will then
speak then we'll turn it over to chief
blackeye and then following chief black
eye we'll hear from district attorney
steve wilson thank you
good morning
i'm evelyn garcia morales school board
trustee the board's vice chair
representing district c
as everyone is aware
we've seen an uptick in violence in some
schools and campuses
well violence in schools is not a new
phenomenon the level of violence
we are witnessing is much worse
on behalf of the board we want to let
you know that we hear
our community loud and clear
while violence in schools is not excuse
me
the school board and the superintendent
and superintendent jara are committed to
addressing these issues swiftly to
ensure that our students and staff feel
safe to come to school and education
continues to be a top priority
disruptions and violence by students
will not be tolerated
if you need help please reach out to a
staff member before resorting to
violence our staff is available to
support and assist students
please reach out and utilize them if you
are struggling
on a very personal note i want to share
that as a mom and aunt of many students
in our school district i know how
worrisome it can feel to send our kids
to school right now
i'm going to encourage all of our
parents and guardians and adults to
check in with their young people
our students need to know that we care
about their well-being
i ask my son every day
what is the best part of your day
what was the most challenging part of
your day
and where did you see kindness
demonstrated by your teachers or peers
these questions really allow me to look
for subtle cues that he either had a
really tough day
or he had a really great day
well i don't don't i don't know what
it's like to be a young person today and
neither of us nobody in this room does
really
i want i know that they're
that we've all experienced this
collective trauma
and are carrying our own anxieties
around it
this is no different for our young
people
it's okay to feel sad
it's okay to feel anxious it's okay to
feel stressed out
as adults we get to model the behaviors
that we want for our students to display
at home and at school
and i implore
our parents and guardians and all adults
who interact with young people to please
talk to your students engage their
well-being every day
now dr jarrell can explain the details
of what will be happening across the
district dr jarrah
thank you um vice president garcia
morales good morning
the uptick in violence we're seeing
across the district
across the community and across the
nation cannot continue
our schools must be
a safe place
for our children and for our staff to
learn and to teach
as i stated a couple weeks ago at the
state of the schools
student on student violence and student
adult violence
that have recently met headlines in our
community and beyond the aggressive
actions we see
mirror the increased violence occurring
in our communities across the country
our children need their parents their
guardians
the community to support and encourage
them in healthy ways of dealing with
their emotions
so talk to your children
be involved and show them your care
and support them
we know that our kids are struggling
because of the stress anxieties and
isolation of the pandemic
but violence
is not
and will never be the answer
we must view our classmates teachers
staff parents administrators through a
lens of share hardships and struggles to
get through this
should students and adults result to
violence on our campus
we will remove them
and hold them accountable according to
our discipline code of conduct
conversations have been going on for a
couple weeks
across the district our staff i can't
thank enough our principals who are here
and others
our principal leads that i have been in
conversations with to address the needs
of our students so thank you for your
leadership as we have been dealing with
what's going on on our campuses
principals will work with their staff to
continue to facilitate discussions and
remind our students of the student code
of conduct
so let me give you some of the details
if students violate the students the
student code of conduct it will be clear
what consequences
will be
they will be responsible for any
physical altercation
will be added as a disciplinary
infraction
fighting is a major infraction on campus
fighting that results in significant
campus disruption
will be a recommended expulsion
from school
all
major disciplinary reflections will
result in a recommended expulsion with
removal from a comprehensive school
campus
with an opportunity for re-engagement
battery to staff or students resulting
in a criminal citation
and distribution of controlled
substances
students recommended for expulsion
for any major disciplinary reflection
will be referred to the following our
academic centers
nevada learning academy
the lighthouse and acceleration academy
we must continue to provide a free and
public education but it doesn't have to
be on our comprehensive schools
students committing these infractions
will require
re-engagement
and rehabilitation
we can't we also know that zero
tolerance
does not work
we have to take care of our children our
precious asset in this community
so we have to find ways
to re-engage them
involving their parents and guardians in
their re-engagement process
act monitoring their academic progress
their positive attendance
completing
the harbor
participating in restorative practices
and services
and anger management
students requiring re-engagement will
receive support from our student success
coordinators
from our counselors our social workers
our mental health services our parent
participation and
continue this cross school collaboration
so
starting today
we will reconvene the expulsion review
board
any student procession in possession of
a firearm
or any dangerous weapon as defined by
nrs will be referred to the expulsion
review board align with the district
policy regulation 51
14.2
we are also
again something that
thanks to
the leadership in our schools
and our facilities
we are going to work and starting this
month
our efforts in
securing our campuses
to make sure that we
provide a single point of entry
we're also working with our elementary
school principals and reset centers
to make sure that we teach our kids
and support them with their emotional
issues and express so they can express
them properly
reset spaces will serve to de-escalate
and refocus behaviors and engage in
restorative practices
we will continue our professional
learning
all staff will participate in
professional learning emergency
procedures processes align to our
student code of conduct
with our multi-tier system of support
additional information will be also
communicated to our schools in the
coming days now you'll hear from
one of our principals mr ryan lewis
president of the principles
actually the administrators association
not just principals
thank you ryan
good morning everybody my name is ryan
lewis i am the principal of gerheim
elementary school
i am not only representing my school
but my colleagues here from elementary
middle school and high school
as the
president of our association
i wanted to highlight
that this year has been a struggle the
struggle is real we live it every single
day um and we wanted to be solution
based in moving forward to helping our
community um
we acknowledge
that we have challenges
we acknowledge that meeting these
challenges is not going to be an easy
task
but we greatly appreciate the
opportunity to collaborate with dr
jarrah and the team to institute some
changes some updates to meet this need
it's going to take some time to do this
but with all of us as a community we
feel like we're up to the task to make
that actually happen and that
collaborative process has really been to
be solution focused um using community
resources school resources um to make a
difference for our kids because we see
it
we know
it's going to be hard but it's worth it
it's definitely worth it
and with that
moving forward we think we can make a
difference
for more children
in a positive base way
which is what we really need at this
point uh is swaying away from the
negative and also focusing on the
positive and what we can do to support
support these kids the last two years
we were just mentioning before have has
taken a toll that's going to take a
couple more years even to come out of
they are really struggling with issues
that are unprecedented
so we have to look at it from a
different lens to help make that happen
so i appreciate the efforts that dr jara
and team are making in collaboration
with us to making the the building level
safer
more productive and
positive outcomes for them in the future
so thank you chief black eye
good morning
mike black i am the chief of clark
county school district police department
this school year so far we've had 38
students struck by vehicles on the way
to or from school several of those have
been fatal
we've confiscated 25 firearms on our
campuses that's inside schools
we've had over a thousand
logged a citations and arrests from our
officers since january
of this year
one new ingredient to
the school violence
that we've been seeing
is parents parents coming onto our
campuses
committing acts of violence to students
to staff
and to each other
that has added to the already high
number of student acts of violence in
our schools
as you as you already know we've we've
reported 3 000
assaults and batteries and fights since
the start of this school year
and we're approaching
spring break
we're approaching the end of the school
year and typically our history shows
that that activity increases
we're asking urging parents to talk to
their students
to their children
ask them
what's going on
in social media check their social media
accounts it seems that since the
pandemic occurred every single person
relied on social media
and everyone's been an expert in in
uploading content to
you know
show what they're doing what they're
experiencing and that's what's happened
this school year it's been a high rate
and as you know constantly you're seeing
uploaded videos of fights and incidents
happening on our campuses
parents please
talk to your students talk to your kids
find out what they're doing who they're
talking to but what friends what what
their friends are doing
that'll help
make sure that they're portraying what
you believe your children are
portraying to you online
if they have a different type of persona
that they're trying to put forward out
there
so we're asking
please
talk to your students talk to your kids
i think that will help
also talk to them about the violence
we're big on mental health
on
addressing those types of incidents
society is not stable right now you know
we have the
the war in ukraine going on we just came
out of a pandemic where
social isolation was
basically all of us live through that
and our kids need help
and we're giving them all the help we
can possibly give them but we need
parents to actually be involved in that
as well
next i'm going to have
steve wilson come up and talk but before
i say that
superintendent and jarrah talked about
not tolerating violent acts in our
schools and
that will continue
so
with the help of las vegas metropolitan
police department henderson police
department and north las vegas police
department
we're working every day to ensure that
the schools remain safe places for our
kids to learn
thank you steve wilson
so before i talk about a very serious
subject i'd like to make a quick
observation dr jorah thank you for
inviting me today
a number of years ago when i was in
school i was always called on last
because my last name began with the w
some things don't change
so thank you for allowing me to speak
the district attorney's office works in
a collaborative partnership
with the school district and the school
police
my lawyers are available 24 7
to respond to schools and to answer
questions
but i can tell you right now school
violence will not be tolerated
and that comes in many forms has been
mentioned
students
staff teachers parents
if there's violence on or near a campus
it cannot be tolerated
there must be consequences
ironically the number of incidents
hasn't increased that much
but the type of
violence has increased the number of
violent
incidences
are on the increase and that's what's
brought so much attention to this
problem
guns on campus in my opinion there
should be the severest of consequences
guns should not be in the hands of
students period
i can't say it anymore simply
guns should not be in the hands of
students let alone being on a school
campus
when i went to high school if you had a
beef with somebody
the little street fighter whatever
occurred off campus i lived down the
street from a
neighborhood park and that's where
students would go and duke it out a
little and that happened once in a while
today it's happening literally in the
classroom
literally in common areas of the
classroom
and it's involving like i said teachers
and staffers and parents it's really a
remarkable thing
what we're experiencing now
as has been said we're all listening to
all of you we're listening to you
teachers
to you police officers
dr jarrah
because we want to work together to try
and change the culture which is
apparently in existence on campus so as
far as the district attorney's office is
concerned
there will be consequences for violence
but at the same time
has been mentioned there are some mental
health issues going on the pandemic
the war in ukraine i mean you're right
uh our kids are listening to the news
and are aware of what's going on it's a
stressful world we live in no doubt
can you imagine being a 10 year old or a
12 year old or a 15 year old and trying
to understand the war in ukraine
and a pandemic where you had to wear a
mask to school for months
maybe not even go to school these are
tough
unique times
but we're a great community i've been in
this town for 41 and a half years
my children went to school here
so we're working together in a
collaborative effort with everybody to
hopefully make some positive change
thank you
thank you district attorney wilson
we'll take questions if you've got them
all right two questions can you give us
an idea of the scale of these changes i
mean you mentioned mandatory expulsion
if this policy has been in effect since
august how many more expulsions are we
talking about is it dozens hundreds
thousands assuming no behavioral changes
oh thank you mike martin for the record
appreciate the question victor uh i
can't predict what the number would have
been but just to give some overview on
the expulsion and what the change is at
this point in time there are particular
infractions uh where they potentially
used to be discretionary in nature
and now as we've said before today
a recommended expulsion infraction for
particular instances including major
fights on campus
campus disruptions
but as far as speculating how that may
have influenced the expulsion numbers
it's hard to say victor
and my second question is for almost a
decade and certainly since the start of
dr jarrah's tenure ccsd has
intentionally been trying to discourage
expulsions and suspensions and as
everyone here knows violence has
increased as discipline has dropped is
this change and acknowledgement that
that approach is wrong
so let me let me so let me help clarify
because you've made two two comments
um for over a decade i've been here four
years victor
um so let's clarify the record um
and what i can tell you is this
and i said it in my in my my statement
the zero time zero tolerance that we've
had experience in the past not here but
across the country in public schools
actually when i was a principal
that does not work
what we are seeing and the work that we
have been doing in collaboration with
the district attorney's office with the
department of juvenile justice is really
about changing behavior
right
changing hold on let
let me let me let me clarify a couple
things um so it's about changing the
behavior of our children because
throwing them out on the streets it will
be now for our police and for the metro
and for the sheriff to have to handle we
have to provide an education
so the work that we have been doing um
not that it's not working we got to
think about it so i got here a year
before the pandemic we started
professional development we are doubling
down on the professional development
some of the comments that i made is
really about re-engagement so we as a
community and as a school district is
we're doubling down on providing the
mental health support for our students
we're involving parents in this
conversation to re-engage them and give
them the
tools necessary so they stay in school
now does it have to be an accompli i was
very clear it doesn't have to be in a
comprehensive school
some students may need a smaller setting
and as we provide
a high quality instruction
so is it working no what i'm saying is
that we are going to improve the systems
because we have seen it work but not as
a whole when we have 366 campuses thank
carr just to you up on that um you know
we have been talking a lot about
restorative justice um
a two-part question one i'm hearing that
it's not being implemented in some
schools and that it could be effective
if it is implemented so can you comment
on how we make sure that it is in every
school and then just to go off of that
just some of the changes and discipline
in the vote of conduct now some severe
how does that play into and now in what
cases would restorative justice be used
rather than the exposure
so what i can tell you and and i i just
want to go back and and thank our
principals um
that when when when mr lewis um from the
elementary and in middle school todd
peterson and also
uh and anthony and i know that um tony
rail and belinda's here and in my
conversations with the principals that's
what you know uh two weeks ago i think
it was at our principal's meeting
um was that we need to do better as a
system on professional development on
restorative practices because they do
work
um so as we are now
going to continue and as i say double
down is to make sure that it's
consistent across the board um again
it's it's it's it's three years um that
we're at this you know for for
for folks to say that
changing a system that has occurred for
over a hundred years and change it in
three years in the midst of a pandemic
that it's perfect absolutely it's not
perfect
i'll be the first one to tell you it's
not perfect but we we can't just toss it
and not continue the work about changing
the behavior so our children can learn
so we're doubling down so making sure
that all schools
are providing a consistent
support system for students around
restorative practices the second
question i'll let dr barton answer that
on
on some of the specific points dr barton
uh thank you dr jarrah so um again the
superintendent made it very clear
restorative justice work takes time uh
there are restorative practices that are
happening and trying to again identify
a perpetrator identifying how they can
correct that issue but let's be very
clear
some infractions that we've mentioned
today will not involve restorative work
if there is an assault
there there aren't restorative measures
but could you repeat the second part of
your question yeah i wanted to ask
because um you talked today about some
like uh and in fact uh an infraction you
need a discretionary so now some of the
rules have changed in the code of
conduct so how does that impact
restorative justice and now what would
be sexual restorative justice
certain infractions require restorative
justice however if there is a
battery on staff battery on student
leading to a citation
that will be a recommended expulsion
along with re-engagement getting to the
root cause of the student's issue around
mental health
but as far as restorative work being
involved in that kind of a case for
instance
that may not occur because honestly to
sit down a victim
with a battery incident with an adult or
student that's been battered uh to sit
down with a perpetrator not appropriate
so but definitely restorative justice
works but it works at those other
infractions where there may be a minor
physical altercation
or a minor fight
the reality is that's where restorative
would work and identifying through the
perpetrator really going deep down
inside on how they can correct their
behavior and do better in the future
superintendent jarrah you said we have
to find ways to re-engage them involving
their parents and guardians in their
re-engagement process and as you
mentioned you're looking to bolster
consequences for students who you know
commit any kinds of acts
um so something that's come up in
me talking to people who work for ccsd
is it kind of depends on the school
whether rpcs are being conducted
required parent conferences and these
are when teachers can say hi uh pair you
know miss jones will you come to my
classroom and this is a required thing
for you know if their student has
been act right um you say you're
doubling down on this so does that mean
that there will be more increased
oversight on ensuring that rpcs are
happening in each and every school
across the board so um when i say
doubling down i think it's more of the
what i'm talking about some of these
other uh
opportunities and courses to involve at
some of the infractions when you're look
the first the first
the first level of i would say support
for families
is if there's issues at home if your
child
is not coming not doing homework not you
know that doesn't want to go to school
call your school i mean your teacher the
counselor
i have
a hundred percent full confidence in our
leaders that they are here to support
our students so that is your first level
of defense
um you know as a parent
having the trustee garcia morale has
said it best it's having that
conversation
if you don't want to come to school
you're not doing don't want to do
homework there's a reason
call the school
call the teacher the counselor and find
out the why right so um that's always
going to be um i used to say to my
teachers i said you know you're if
you're seeing things that are your the
students are acting a little bit
different is make a phone call home it
doesn't have to always be negative it's
got to be a ways to engage that family
so that is also where i'm going to be an
oversight and monitor absolutely not i
have full confidence in our principles
that they're going to continue
to provide that support at school for
our
discussed
parents
some of the changes that we've seen
among parents
what kind of
efforts are you making in that regard
well
i i i
i can control the 305 000 students um as
far as parents i mean i think our chief
was very clear i mean what we're seeing
of parents coming on to our campuses
this is where this is the what we're all
here
uh as as a district we need the
community support
we need
if you have an issue even as adults
call
and get help
you heard the district attorney office
you heard of police officers their
support here let us know so then we're
fine but coming on to a school
where children can see that it just
continues to exacerbate the problem and
i think that's where
i would ask for parents to
you know go into the community and get
the support they need
i understand a couple years ago the
school district addressed the issues of
gangs
in the schools do you know if any gang
element is
connected to the issues of guns
chief
well that question can be answered by
lieutenant brian zink we do have a
detective assigned to metro gang unit
that works directly with them and
investigates those incidents
we also are part of the
crime gun intelligence center with the
atf and metro where each firearm that is
confiscated off school property
is
then delivered and
immediately evaluated by that group
so we get an immediate result um on the
activity surrounding that that firearm
yeah
further on they were talking about the
safety aspect and having the
one entry point um when will that be
implemented and then
you know a big discussion has been metal
detectors um are there schools with
metal detectors
as well so um as far as what single
point of entry we we've gone through the
list um and and you know these are
things that um
our principals have put in work orders
and and and and we've got the list we've
got we're going to streamline that and
we're going to fast track it our
facilities department will start with
you know
have a list of priority schools we are
going to hopeful you know there will be
good news i don't know if they know yet
but we are going to fund it centrally
this is a this is their our campuses as
a central responsibility so we'll start
that work
um you know we're within the next
few weeks right it just started go
addressing the one point of entry and
then also our portables that are exposed
is how do we then put some fencing
around
our portables to protect our kids
so so that's going to start within the
next couple weeks
as far as
there's been a lot of discussion about
metal detectors so we do we have okay so
i want to be very clear and and i'll let
the experts i'm not the expert our
police department is the expert um on on
the metal detectors and we've had i've
been in other places where experts have
come in and metal detectors
um you know it's it's um it's a
challenge to get three thousand four
thousand kids to school on time we the
metal detectors that we do have we use
them for football games
uh but that is not the answer for this
right now um we we will not be using
metal detectors to walk in
this is not about um
this is not about hardening our schools
um our schools need to be inviting and a
safe space uh for our children we do
have a different strategy we do random
searches
uh we have we've had doubled um i would
say
our canine
you know that come into our and and do
random searches across the entire our
schools randomly selected um and we do
some of those random searches not only
with canine but then also within our our
school leaders so
that and and and maybe the chief can
speak to that um but that seemed to you
know when we were doing that before
covid
um we saw a decrease in the number of
guns that we found so that is the
strategy that a superintendent we're
going to continue doing
so basically we are we're looking at our
at our facilities because we have open
campuses i mean we have
um i think principal um kevin mcmarlin
is here from arbor view they're open
campuses they're beautiful campuses but
it's just
there's too many kids coming in and out
and and and it makes it that more of a
challenge so we're going to then
put some put some systems and and
fencing and you know i'm not
the head of the facilities here but
we're going to find ways to make sure
that um we we
limit all the entry points so then all
the kids come into one campus
uh we do have we have a list of schools
that have that are wide open we have
some already that are
in that point so
we're looking at that list and we're
going to expedite the process there
thank you for the question um so the
expulsion review board is is set in
policy and it's comprised of trustees
trustees typically haven't been involved
in
the due process hearing panels but the
expulsion review board has trustees as
members board of school trustees
retired administrators with knowledge
about disciplinary practices
and they hear cases and that's where
determinations are made there are
multiple levels of due process for
students in the district that
lead up to an expulsion review board but
ultimately with the firearms we're going
directly to that expulsion review board
because of the serious nature of those
infractions
thank you for the question again mike
barton for the record uh we we have
we have seats available at academic
centers as we call them behavior schools
we've had a reduction in the number of
behavior schools over the last several
years
as far as
the dean question
we've pivoted that role to a different
position in the district where it's more
of a
less punitive role but they're still
involved in discipline but again they're
interacting with counselors mental
health professionals to ensure that
we're getting to the root cause of
behaviors and that was a change that we
made three years ago with the pivot of
that dean's position
that's correct yes we don't intend to
reinstate deans at this time this role
is a relatively new role but again it's
focused on getting to the antecedent or
the root cause of behaviors and and we
again
we're training those folks to be
around discipline but also
how do we work with family students
teachers to promote a safe learning
environment
great question we don't we we view with
what we've announced today we have the
academic centers or behavior schools
that will be utilized for infractions
however we also discussed earlier the
nevada learning academy where there are
options online
and there will be services for
re-engagement provided even with those
opportunities that are temporary
disciplinary placements
superintendent
if you can talk a little bit about just
the frustration in general for the
school district
you know
how did we get here and moving forward
how do you also
or what message do you have for your
staff to lift up
yeah
so it's a great question
well i i couldn't predict the pandemic
in my years of study
i i never predicted that we would be
in this situation
and
i never predicted that we'd be
at this place
where we are today
um not something in in
and you know my principals who are here
and in schools and staff
it is frustrating um it's it's
it's not um
it's the hardest thing i've ever done in
my career
leading
a school district
through a world pandemic that the entire
world shut down the economy
when
we close schools i thought it was gonna
be two weeks
um and we're gonna be back and and
reopen schools
um then it came you know through
through months and months
so
when we opened we were all excited i
said march 1st of last year when we saw
our children back in school for the
hybrid it was the best day that i've
experienced
um coming back seeing kids in school
seeing our teachers
and our principals
giving it all
and also opening up a school system as
big as we are
i'm proud of the work that we've done
with all our bargaining units
i said this last night because they're
school systems
that open and shut down
and they're in current lawsuits with
their unions our union stepped up
up and said we're going to do this
safely for our staff but get way they
understood how critical
our kids needed to be in school how
important that was
and then
um we opened up and and
and we saw
i would tell you we saw
our kids
struggle because they were home and
isolated they were on computers
um you know that
and and and
my my colleagues who are here the
principals said that to me we've never
seen some of the behavior where kids
were at home unsupervised in some cases
because parents had to work
[Music]
so i couldn't be more proud of
as frustrated as i
am and i have been i couldn't be more
proud of working with the leaders
to find solutions
um as they came in and said boss soup we
get we we're seeing this and how do we
address it
and coming together so i ask our our
teachers um our staff our 42 000
employees i thank them for their work
you know um
i'm going to tell a little because last
last week i was um
actually sunday um and somebody said you
know we we did
um and celebrated nurses
we celebrated
um
everybody out in the community well how
about celebrating our educators
we never closed down
we shifted to a distance said these
folks
still delivered education
but just from home
for the fifth largest school district in
the country to do that
is remarkable
right
so i just say to this community
celebrate our educators
because when this school system closed
down and this community closed down we
served over 21 million meals
to this
community
and they're tired
but they're coming in and showing up
those who are coming in so there is a
level of frustration but you know what
you can't you you
you can't
give up
because our kids
need to be educated so tell the teachers
that i hear them and this is why we're
all here
um our our parents
be part of the solution
so we can help our kids
get to where they need to be
thank you superintendent uh thank you uh
for the question
so the the expulsion recommendations
will be around the campus disruption if
a fight is determined to be a major
major fight involves or a student that's
been involved in multiple fights or
attempts to try to bring others on
campus to fight that will be deemed a
campus disruption and again as stated
before will be a recommended expulsion
recommendation
uh fights
uh typically are are are major and those
could lead to a referral to a academic
center as we described physical
altercation which is being added to the
code of conduct is more for minor
infractions but the reason for the
change in the code of conduct swiftly
right now was again to highlight that
campus disruption
where those major fights occur
will lead to a discretionary expulsion
recommendations
our focus is obviously our staff our
employees their safety is paramount
along with our students
so as far as talking to students talking
to
our employees i think that you know
we've had several meetings with student
groups
students have seen this
this uptick in violent acts
and so what we've learned is that
there's this
lower level of connectedness on campuses
and again this is all related to what
the superintendent described our
pandemic school closures so how are we
building bridges back on our communities
to make sure that students feel
connected to those staff that you
mentioned so we're working really hard
to ensure that a number one
our schools feel safe for students and
our staff
thank you everybody
uh
you